Chad its ross we've only ever spoken I
think once or twice and this is an
honest question is it Chad Johnson right
now or Chad Ochocinco you know what it's
whatever you were gonna say it doesn't
mean doesn't matter what it says on
paper when you see me however you feel
the need to address me that's how you do
it
God okay cool I like that I like the
flexibility there well you're at Osho
Cinco on Twitter you have a great new
podcast with Jaime dukes that drops on
Wednesday which is fantastic I'm curious
now that you've been removed from the
league for a couple years do you look
back on you know all the things you did
from an entertainment perspective are
you glad that that's the way you handled
yourself or do you wish you had done a
little bit done it a little bit
differently I am glad I did it exactly
the way I did it if I had the
opportunity to do it again I'd probably
do it the exact same way and add a few
things that I wasn't able to do because
of my I like to call this early
departure from my transit or actually
have an opportunity to place into my own
stupidness but I wouldn't change a thing
I wouldn't say anything and I think I
would regret not doing things my way now
that I'm removed from the game four or
five years removed if I didn't do it my
way that was like and I could have done
this I could have done it this way and
the game of football and we tend to
forget at times is a game of
entertainment it's a game of
entertainment and I did just that I did
it the right way also being able to be
extremely extremely productive week in
and week out yeah and you know Chad it's
interesting I think I said during the
break I don't remember any guy from the
bangles since ickey woods having
commercials before you and I don't make
me I'm sure dalton has something or AJ
green maybe by I don't really remember
guys from the bangles having any
commercials since you on some level
obviously Carson and the team success
but on some level you
and the way you performed and the way
you entertained really put that
franchise back on the map and I can see
why you like the way you bait imeem you
you benefited significantly off the
field don't you think yeah somewhat from
what some of the things I did were found
the pun some lorem I think if I wasn't
as for excessive as I was some of the
extra shenanigans some of the things I
did also feel would have you know would
have been used as a reason as to why you
know things were the way they were but
being that I was able to produce week in
and week out year after year and be
consistent somewhat I was able to get
away with doing some of the extras hey
we're talking with Chad Johnson Chad
Ochocinco check him out on Twitter at
hose Cinco here on the Dan Patrick show
and check out his podcast as well with
Jamie Dukes that drops on Wednesday
mornings you know Chad we saw
D'Brickashaw Ferguson surprisingly
retire on Friday before that it was
Calvin Johnson we've got Marshawn Lynch
it seems like a bunch of guys that could
still play at a pretty high level are
our retiring was still having some game
left I would not have been one of those
guys I think I would have played until
the wheels came off but I also didn't
make the money that some of these guys
made do you think that they're doing it
more Chad because the money's so big now
that they've made so much or do you
think that you know the CTE and the head
stuff is really a factor and why it at
least appears as if more and more guys
are stepping away earlier than ever
before that's a great question and I
think if you ask each individual that
retires you just named three I think you
get you you get three different answers
if you ask all three of them why they
decided to let the game and normally the
time that answers that they give you on
why the answers to the media or to the
public
they're always politically correct but I
mean I want the real like the homeboy me
and the homeboy no cameras no really
something that's the answer I would like
for most individuals it's just Marshawn
Lynch and Calvin Johnson
on why you decided to hang it up and I
think realistically and what what it is
I would say to me I would say injury I
would say the body is beat up and I
think what they're doing is is they're
letting go of the game before the game
let's go with him if that makes sense
what would you tell them Chad if they
asked you like if and maybe Calvin did
but if they asked you because I got the
sense that when you were done even just
talking to you nail that you wish you
could have played a couple more years
what would you have said if Calvin asks
you for advice you know the game you
understand the politics of the game it's
happened to every great receiver there
is and what you want to do is you want
to get all of yours
as fast as possible because there's a
small window for us or for you in
general and I'm not sure what it would
have been but if you feel the need to
walk away and you can't perform at a
high level and be the Calvin Johnson
that you've been over the years then I
say it's okay if you can still go and
still give it Calvin Johnson and we can
a week out and I expect that wouldn't
that would be my advice Chad who is your
favorite receiver in the league right
now forget you know who the best is but
who is just your favorite and why I have
a tie I have a tie but when you talk
about favorites you know I'm not sure if
I'm able to do this matter of fact my
name unit I might be quad core group me
no no when faced with ripples I have
this problem I love old ale I love
Antonio Brown and I love AJ Green now
you have three different receivers you
have three different receivers that get
it done three different types of waves
it depends on what you like personally
personally I like Antonio Bryant on what
he can do as far the receiver in the
inside outside and he either he's a
master route runner and can do it from
the outside and inside and he also adds
a special team element
to his game as well I like Odell for the
entertainment value being able to
produce also being able to at a high
level from the outside or the inside as
well and AJ Green is just freakish
because a freakish athlete he's a
freaking savage that I enjoy watching
each and every Sunday when I have the
opportunity to watch the bank you know
it's interesting we're wrapping up with
Chad Johnson check him out on Twitter at
a chosen Inco about 3 million of you or
more do he's also got a new podcast with
Jamie Dukes that drops every Wednesday
last time I was filling in Chad for Dan
I had Gary Myers on the show and he's a
Hall of Fame voter and he talked about
how they didn't vote for tio this year
and LARC because of the things he did in
the locker room and his I don't wanna
say off the field behavior but I guess
in the locker room behavior and thinking
that that had an impact on things that
happened on the field and I know tio
came out recently and said he thinks
that the Hall of Fame should be based
solely on your statistics I'm curious as
to where you stand on that or in that
discussion isn't that the whole team is
about it and you know Emily am I correct
my Hall of Fame is about your sass your
accolades and what you're able to do in
between the lines of the game right well
evidently evidently according to a lot
of the voters Chad it's it's about more
than that why is that why is that that
has nothing to do you telling me that
you just you're making the Hall of Fame
based on what you do off the field yeah
the way you carry yourself I think the
thought yeah I think the thought process
Chad or at least this how it was
described to me is that the thing is
that t/o did in the locker room
negatively impacted his team's chances
of winning and that that's what the Hall
of Fame is about how much you
contributed to your team being better
we talked about Terrell Owens right
there singing Terrell Owens how do you
have you seen his numbers have you seen
what he does once he touched the field
hey I'm with you man he would he would
have gotten in ahead of Marvin Harrison
on my vote there's no question about it
he would get it ahead of anyone because
he impacts a team in a positive way once
he touches the field what happens in the
locker room doesn't matter what happens
outside a locker room doesn't matter
he is a difference maker once he touches
the field his impact on the field is
magnificent period case closed his
personality how we act how he carried
himself has should have anything to do
with getting into the Hall of Fame this
is the thing this is life this is why I
don't really care much for it I don't
really care much for because it's a
group of individuals that are voting you
in where we're supposed to play and be
proud and need this validation which for
me this validation okay will you play
run enough and you acted and you acted a
certain way and you conform to the way
we felt you should have played like so
we're gonna let you in a soup of these
people yeah that's not what it's about
that's not what it's about
and if for some reason it's like so it's
so clawed to the point where I don't
even care because it's like everybody
everybody leaves this validation to say
oh you're Hall of Famer you were great I
was great whether I wear the yellow
jacket or not our great woody let me in
your little secret society or not the
numbers speak for themselves
I don't need the jacket I don't need the
rules that are oh he was great no I was
great during my time the numbers speak
for themselves the film the eye on the
sky doesn't lie and the same thing goes
for tea oh yes he had his problems we
all had we all do have them but to say
oh we're not going to vote him in
because he did this in the locker we had
this incident it has nothing to do with
Hall of Fame at all and listen to do it
at all well I kind of thought you'd feel
that way and my argument is how do they
really know what happened in the locker
room that's been
you know everything is controlled by the
media everything's controlled by the
media the media is the media drives
everything yeah no I'm with it and I'm
in it now I'm in it now Chad you kind of
are as well with the podcast thanks for
hopping aboard man hey I love you and
everybody listening if you guys need me
just call me there is check him out on
Twitter there is Chad Ochocinco good
stuff there I love that he called the
Hall of Fame the secret society the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience